[Music]
who said that vandals were bad people
some of them are there to make things
change and those we love the most are
here to make us smile just wait until
you see what happened when pac-man
invaded the streets if this is your
first time visiting this channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you 15 random acts of genius
vandalism aliens you might think that
crossing the street is safe when there
are no cars around
but you shouldn't only look to the right
and to the left to see if there are any
cars you should also look up at the sky
to make sure that a spaceship is not
there to get you this kind of alien
invasion doesn't happen every day but
these extraterrestrials seem to always
be hanging around the same places that's
why someone is here to warn us against
alien abduction if you ever cross the
street in this city you might be
transported into another universe you
might think that extraterrestrials don't
exist but there are actually five traits
that could get you abducted by aliens
according to Graham CL Devi it's sleep
paralysis a tendency to recall false
memories high levels of absorption New
Age beliefs and a familiarity with the
cultural narrative of alien abduction so
you were right to think that we don't
have any proof that aliens exist those
who think that they've seen one are not
crazy minions when there is a fire you
can count on fire fighters to save you
they will quickly come to your place and
use a fire hydrant to allow water to
flow into their hoses fire hydrants are
usually red to make sure that they will
be able to quickly find them but with so
many red things around us it can be hard
for the fire hydrant to stand out this
is why someone decided to make sure that
everyone would see it by transforming it
into a minion not only will it save us
from a fire but it will also save us
from having a bad day how can anyone not
smile when they see this and if you want
to laugh even more you have to watch
Despicable Me remember the fire alarm
scene in the second movie these yellow
creatures quickly tried to save the
situation in the worst way possible by
smashing the wall screaming and trying
to use a hose this was probably one of
the most memorable scenes of the movie
bTW we all remember the popular 1982
movie et the extra-terrestrial and one
funny vandal made sure that all the men
would never forget it however women
might not have the chance to see this
and you know why that's because he
recreated one of the final scenes in the
men's bathroom any of us would think
that it was just a normal light but
someone actually saw the moon this is
why they decided to put a sticker of our
favorite extraterrestrial on the light
going to the bathroom has
never been so entertaining but did you
know that everything in the famous scene
was real except Eliot mu T visual
effects supervisor Dennis Muren and his
team were asked to create special
effects for the movie but surprisingly
for the final scene he barely used any
it took him weeks to find the right spot
to film the scene and use maps and
charts to coordinate it then he just had
to add the two characters and that's how
he got that beautiful result that is
still iconic nowadays jellyfish we're so
used to seeing these signs and bathrooms
that we didn't even take time to take a
closer look at it but when you stare at
them for too long while washing your
hands you notice that they don't make
sense at all take a look at this one for
example you might think that it's just
about drying your hands but one animal
lover saw a jellyfish that we should
applaud instead sure we would applaud
this weird creature if we could but none
of them came out of this hand dryer and
this is probably a good thing because
jellyfish probably won't dry your hands
that's because they are 85% to 98% water
they even squirt water from their mouths
to be propelled forward but what is more
impressive is that with all this water
they don't even have enough place for a
brain a heart or lungs
now that's one unique creature that we
should applaud pothole flowers we all
hate potholes and if you're a Canadian
you hate them even more because they are
just everywhere you can't drive in a
straight line in Canada because there
are always many holes on the road that
you need to avoid and when you think
that you finally found a way to avoid
them you find out that the street is
blocked because they're trying to repair
those potholes once again this is why
one nice person decided to make them
more enjoyable by putting flowers in
them and we couldn't be happier when
driving to work but do you know why
there are so many potholes in Canada
it's because of winter when snow or rain
seeps into the soil below the road it
freezes causing the ground to expand and
pushing the pavement up then when the
temperature rises the ground returns to
normal but it creates a gap that a car
will soon drive over and that's how
potholes are created cars there are
still some things that we can enjoy
during winter in Canada no one likes
when their car is covered with snow and
they have to wake up earlier in the
morning to make sure that they'll be
able to go to work on time but someone
made sure that they would be starting
their day in the best way they drove
funny faces on the snow in their cars
and they even shared a picture to make
sure that everyone would be able to see
this this is what we call Canadian
vandalism even the Vandals are too
polite to do anything that people won't
like however these people will have to
clear the snow off their car even if it
looks good and you know why it's because
you can receive it
or even the accuse of criminal
negligence if you drive with too much
snow on your car so unfortunately these
funny faces will have to go away but
we'll have a picture to remember it
forever stairway to heaven when you wake
up early in the morning to go to school
the last thing you want to do is take
the stairs to go to the fifth floor
you're just never ready to be exhausted
just before spending a long day in class
this is why someone decided to make
things more interesting for everyone on
his way to class as they walked by the
second floor they simply wrote one word
on the wall and we bet that it made
everyone laugh that day this is how
stairway 2 was transformed into the
famous song stairway to heaven by Led
Zeppelin but did you know that the rock
band was actually accused of copying the
song the group spirit thought that it
was too similar to their song torus and
filed a lawsuit against them fortunately
they were able to prove that the two
songs were not really similar and Led
Zeppelin won speed limit we're all in a
love-hate relationship with speed limits
we all wish that we could go just a
little faster when we're going to be
late
but at the same time we understand that
it is here to protect us usually these
signs are pretty simple after all when
you're driving 80 miles an hour you want
to make sure that you can easily see the
speed limit in a second but someone
decided to make things more complicated
by adding one of the most terrible
things in the world to this sign
mathematics just imagine everyone
stopping by the side of the street to
try to solve this problem it could be
really dangerous and you know what is
more dangerous driving just a little
faster if we increase traffic speeds of
just 3 miles per hour there would be 25
more fatal accidents every year and more
than a hundred serious injuries if we
can avoid it by driving just a little
slower we should do it no unit browse
skateboards are cool not only do they
give us the chance to travel faster but
we can also impress our friends with
impressive tricks unfortunately it seems
like many haters are jealous of some
skateboarders talent because they
decided to ban them people knew that
they couldn't break the rules so they
decided to change them instead and this
is how they transform the sign into
something that no one likes unibrow x'
if you have one on your face you won't
have the chance to go anywhere near this
place until you wax it tom winter will
be happy to hear about this because he
loves to skateboard and can't go
anywhere without it the professor who
was then 69 years old was seen
skateboarding on the University of
Nebraska campus he was so popular that
he even became a meme now that's one
good reason to go to college we want to
meet this funny man
do not touch when someone tells us not
to do something it just makes us want to
do it even more for example when we see
sign that reads fresh paint we want to
touch the wall just to make sure that it
is true sometimes the problem is also
that these signs are there for nothing
and we don't mind breaking the rules
that shouldn't be there in the first
place but this time we totally
understand why we shouldn't touch
something no matter how bad you might be
it is always important to respect nature
and this little vandal did it in the
best way unfortunately if we can't touch
this dandelion it won't be able to make
our wishes come true but do you know
where this strange belief comes from in
the 1800s young girls believe that if
they blew on it and all the seeds flew
away their loved one would return their
feelings if any seeds remained it
probably wouldn't work with them this
makes us want to touch the standing lion
anyway to see what will happen
snakes most people are terrified of
snakes and we would all wish to see a
sign to warn us that there is one nearby
but maybe people have been trying to
tell you this for decades and you just
didn't understand what they meant when
you look at this sign you think that
someone just slipped on a wet floor but
there is a person who saw something else
this is why they decided to warn
everyone by telling them that one in
every three snakes would make you fall
actually we'd rather think that this is
just water on the floor because it's
less terrifying but snakes aren't always
mean after all you know that their venom
could have terrible consequences but
scientists also found out that it could
be used in medicine to save lives so
even though one in three snakes can make
you fall the two others could help you
go back on your feet right after the
superheroes we often see broken things
on the street and we just keep wondering
how someone even managed to do that
these things are meant to stay there for
a long time and it would take someone
really strong to make them move this is
why a funny vandal decided to recreate
the scene that could explain what
happened and we love their theory
according to them there was a fight
between ant-man and yellowjacket right
in the middle of the street that could
explain a lot of weird things that are
happening there at night but you might
not like this superhero anymore once you
know who he truly was at the beginning
the film was meant to focus on the
original ant-man Pym who developed
several personalities and was violent
with people he loved rejecting this idea
and turning him into a supporting
character was probably one of the best
things that they ever did we want to see
a hero that we can all love rainforests
sometimes it is sad to walk around the
city everything around you is grey and
sad including the buildings the sky and
the ground even when there are trees
they look like they don't even want to
be here this is why any plant that is
still beautiful and green easily stands
out this is how someone found a tiny
rainforest on the pavement where they
were walking it
we made them smile and this is why they
wanted to make sure that everyone would
have a good day to they wrote on the
ground that it was a tiny rainforest and
turned these little plants into
something magic but did you know that
there is one good reason why rainforests
are actually much more amazing than you
would think
they make up 6% of the Earth's land
surface but produce 40 percent of its
oxygen we wouldn't be there without them
so we need to give rainforests the
attention they deserve Cookie Monster if
there is one thing that our dog would
like to become it's a trash can you're
probably wondering why but it's because
they notice that it's where all the food
that we don't eat goes and our furry
friends are jealous when they see that
we don't give them the last bite of our
steak and put it in the trash can
instead
Cookie Monster is one funny character
who decided to make this dream come true
to make sure that we wouldn't waste any
cookies he transformed himself into a
trash can but he won't be happy to hear
that he's just a recycle bin so he'll
just be eating paper instead did you
know that Cookie Monster is also a Carly
Rae Jepsen fan he actually sang a song
about cookies inspired by the hit single
called share it maybe
the female singer sounds way better but
we think that Cookie Monster is really
funnier pac-man when we were kids we
could turn anything into a game and when
we cross the street we made sure that we
stepped on every line if we didn't we
believed that something terrible would
happen however it will be difficult to
do it this time because pac-man is
eating them you better hurry up if you
want to cross the street in safety we
don't know what inspired this person but
they decided to paint over the lines and
paint the famous yellow character
instead but did you know that the game
was originally made to attract email
players with food it was supposed to be
more violent but creators thought it
would be better to make pac-man eat
yellow dots because women like to have
dessert after eating dinner we
understand why this game was so popular
not only women but everyone loves food
did you ever see any act of genius
vandalism don't be shy to tell us what
it was in the comment section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it for 15 random acts of genius
vandalism for more stories like this
make sure to watch 10 weird things all
kids do thanks for watching
[Music]